[Applause]
the only scary thing about halloween
should be your costume not your safety
but today we're going to give you our
favorite coveted safe halloween costume
ideas
with the world renowned fashion designer
and friend of the show christian siriano
this is how i keep social distance and i
love a big wedge of cheese and then i
have my two baguettes that can basically
point to the designated six feet away
from me
please stay away from me don't
touch me it works don't touch me don't
get near me we cannot do that
okay you're bad guys before we bring
anyone out um what should people keep in
mind for their costumes this year
okay i think it you can still have fun
we you know we're not taking away
halloween be glamorous be exciting
i mean and if you're waist up that's the
more the better and
math everybody looks great in a mask
than halloween i mean isn't it everybody
perfect that halloween is all about
masks
and if you like weren't looking cute
like early in the week you could have a
great mass that covers it all
yes i know every time i get a mask knee
i'm like
i cover it up with more mask knee or
more mask okay let's bring out our first
guest
um our first look is chris the beekeeper
this is major ah this is it
who is bringing out a dog who may or may
not want to be here his name is harley
oh my god he's so cute
the bee took a trip okay by the way this
is my producing partner chris miller
so i just have to call that out we've
been at flower films together for almost
25 years
uh chris how are you liking your outfit
liking it are you not saying anything in
case you don't want like a sag
card like fee yeah perfect got it
okay i'm loving it you're fabulous
keeper there's a mask he's social
distance with the bees
perfect also i think a bee insinuates
like
i'm gonna sting you if you get close to
me this one's actionable thank you chris
miller i love you
my brother from another mother okay
next we have naomi who's rocking
oh yeah oh yeah
this is one way to keep your distance
honey
just blow up it's also like you can eat
anything for lunch
anything like you can eat like all the
candy oh the beans
and broccoli i was going with candy
you're going with whole foods
[Laughter]
look at a mask inside and plastic you're
so kind by the way naomi you look really
gorgeous actually i'm not kidding and
the moon boots like
you i have to tell you this is this is
looks how i feel
sometimes after eating at whole foods
which i love um
uncomfortable yes i love this how are
you feeling naomi
like you could fly off to the moon
fabulous well thank you naomi okay
next we have beach ball nick
i love it oh can't go to the bahamas
this year
well good news it's sunny somewhere
this is like a florida halloween costume
you know so you
look you can't come near you like in the
back it's like you kind of bump well
kristen if you do the twisting and i do
the baguetting
and all three of us can be near each
other and yet we're completely safe
and i will say that you're giving me
major holiday vibes and as the weather
gets colder
you want to go somewhere yes you are
transporting me oh god there goes my
oh dear here we go i love a floral mask
too this is all about costumes that look
great with the mask this looks great
christian look what's happening to my
bad guy
[Laughter]
it didn't it's yeah it's not done
well anyway nick i think you look
fantastic
i love your beach ball christian i love
you so much
i'm your gay cowboy and i am your wheel
of
by the way i could be a stinky cheese
yeah that's my mom which just
also means like oh no no that's why i'm
over here
oh i got a limp baguette
it happened it died it certainly does
thank you christian
i love hanging out with you i love this
fashion show you look great
this is so fun happy halloween everybody